I study whiskers
because they're just the best.
Most mammals, they have
whiskers, and what's exciting
about them is that there's so
much stuff that we don't know.
I like to look at something
that we see every day
and then find out really cool
and interesting things
about them.
Lots of people,
when they hear about whiskers,
they think immediately
of cat whiskers.
But, actually, other animals
have much better whiskers -
they're more sensitive,
they're bigger,
they move
more than cats' whiskers.
Porcupine whiskers are just
the longest whiskers I've seen.
The one that I've got back
in the lab is about 45 cm long,
and they move them
almost continually,
and then they kind of bump
and move and vibrate
around over the material
that they're on
so you can really see that
they're moving all the time.
Hi, gorgeous!
It's very difficult to study
the evolution of whiskers
because hair isn't really
preserved in the fossil record.
So we have a look at
this little hole here
which is called the
infraorbital foramen,
or whisker holes.
And all the information
from the whiskers,
from those sensitive follicles,
travel through that hole
and into the brain.
Humans are really quite unusual
to not have whiskers.
But we do still have
these whisker holes
where our whiskers
would have been
and, also, we even have
some remnants of muscles,
similar to what we see
in animals with whiskers.
Whiskers are very much
like human fingertips.
Lots of animals can move
their whiskers
and then some animals engage
in what is called whisking.
So this is cyclic forward
and backward movements
that the animals make
with their whiskers.
And we might think of this
as scanning.
So, when we walk into a room,
we might be looking around
everywhere,
trying to see all around us,
and that's what these guys
are doing.
And the fastest whisking
that I've seen
has been in harvest mice,
which reach up to
about 25 times per second,
which are some of
the fastest movements
that mammals can make.
The most sensitive whiskers
are in aquatic mammals.
Lots of seals will have kind of
just under 2,000 nerve fibres
surrounding all of
those whiskers in the follicle
and their whiskers
are so sensitive
they can do this amazing thing
which is called
hydrodynamic sensing.
So, as a fish swims through the
water, it leaves behind a wake,
a trail of water movement,
and the seals are able
to detect this.
And they use
only their whiskers for this.
These are porcupine whiskers
and you can see
that they're arranged into
a grid, or whisker map.
So you have rows and columns
of whiskers.
So they're very ordered.
The same grid-like pattern
can be seen
in physical structures
through the brain,
and now neuroscientists
love this because it means
they can actually
tweak one whisker here,
so a middle whisker,
and they can follow it
through the entire brain
to see where
that sensory signal goes,
and each physical structure
will light up in turn.
In many animals,
whiskers are their primary
and most important sense.
So it's very, very important
not to trim them.
It wouldn't hurt them,
but they'll suddenly
remove a sense.
So it would be like
if you blindfolded us
and then put us in a room,
and so we've got to feel around
to work out where we are,
and that is what these animals
are doing all the time.
We can see that,
when we look at rats and mice,
that some of them will actually
engage in a behaviour
called barbering.
So this is when you have
a dominant individual
that will trim the whiskers,
so bite off the whiskers
of their family
or other people
that live in their box.
And so, when they do that,
those individuals will become
more submissive.
So it establishes
this hierarchy within the cage.
Whiskers can inspire lots of
new technology and innovations.
Firstly, we can have a look
at their shape.
So the undulations
of seal whiskers has inspired,
for instance, turbine blades.
So turbine blades
can be extra-aerodynamic
because they have these amazing
undulations or waves
along them.
These could also be applied
to tidal energy, as well.
Then you have the fact
that they are sensors.
You can put these sensors
onto robots.
So, then, you can have
tactile robots or whisker bots.
And these could be
really useful
for something even like
a robot hoover.
But also to make sure
that robots can go
into hazardous, dark
or complex environments.
These are the environments
we need our robots to go into.
So people don't really think
about whiskers at all.
You probably go home
and look at your cat
or your gerbil or your rabbit
and you think, "Oh, yeah,
"they're fluffy
and have whiskers."
But, actually, what we're doing
is trying to understand,
"Well, how do they work,
and how sensitive are they,
"and what do they
use them for?"
And I think that that's
super interesting to find out.